well I'm a Canadian so I'm loathe to get
involved in your in your election I'm
mad at my own government so here's is
not me coming down and lecturing you our
governments also what we call the bush
lite I mean they've done the same kind
of you know hands off of the environment
handing over our clean our protections
of for clean water and so on so I
haven't heard so with from what I've
seen and I watched pretty closely
television we get all your stations and
all your media I haven't heard nearly
enough talk about the environment from
any of the candidates in either of the
parties and I it's I mean Healthcare's
tremendously important and the economy
and so on but it tends to be more those
and I still think we're missing this
subject we're certainly missing them
water subject you just don't hear the
issue of water and I don't understand it
I mean I was in Utah for the sundance
film festival in January and I mean this
is a state running out of water and
there and then depending on the snow
melt from the mountains right and
they're cutting down those trees in
those bushes that protect the snow so
fast you know and and there was no no
talk of it you know I didn't see sign
saying please conserve our water we're
running out of water it reminded me of
this far side cartoon where there's
these dogs and a raft and the big ships
going down right you can see they've
been you know they've jumped in a life
raft and one of them says okay everybody
in favor of eating all the food at once
put your hands up right it's like we're
running out of water maybe if we cut
down some more trees we can really run
out of water fast and I stated this and
is one of these thousands of condos they
have and and the shower had to to to you
know speeds often hurt you know it
showered so hard it was going to like so
it's that level of consciousness that we
need and I guess it's not going to come
from the top I think it's going to have
to bubble up from the bottom in this
movement that's also here in the United
States of people fighting for their
water rights whether it's fighting in
Mount Shasta California against Nestle
taking their
off the mountains or in Fryeburg Maine
where they're fighting Poland Springs or
you know or declare the river keepers
who are doing wonderful work cleaning up
america's rivers or the Clean Water
Action Network I mean there are so many
groups that are fighting or food and
water watch corporate accountability
international doing wonderful work on
bottled water take back the tap
campaigns I you know I think it's going
to come more from the bottom and one
enough of us care which is why I wrote
the book which is why there are these
wonderful films there's a new film
called flow for love of water with a
wonderful woman director named arena
Selena who lives here in New York which
one the Mumbai film festival and was
premiered at sundance these with these
films and books were hoping to get
people really understanding the crisis
upon us and that we should not and I
hope we don't have to wait until we're
turning on the water and it's not there
talk to somebody yesterday who was in
Pakistan and went to the Bhutto family
home this is before benazir bhutto was
murdered and seventy-five percent of
people in Pakistan have no access to
clean water none seventy-five percent
they showed them in there that they
turned on the water and no water came
out of the tap think about that no water
came out of the tap now the budos are
wealthy so they truck pure water in you
know they don't care where it comes from
but if you're not wealthy think about
turning on the tap and no water coming
out I mean when I first discovered
really discovered water right in the
poor community and Bolivia years ago and
I really looked at it I can came home to
my house in ottawa canada and i said i
looked around at my own water access
right i'm not rich i have seven at
outlets for water in my house if you
count the laundry room in the kitchen
and the bathrooms and then you know the
little tap out front a note back and so
on and i could put them all on at once
if i wanted and i could just run it and
nobody would say anything who would know
it this just this this access that we
have and this this way of looking at it
is if it will never dry up and that we
have this right to it and other people
in the world
none and I'm but if I keep saying to
people you don't care for yourself if
the others have none doesn't bother you
it will come here it is going to visit
here this is the world people need to
see the world as like a living organism
and just like the blood that runs
through your veins is is all a part of
everything and if you poison it here
it's going to hit back here or here
right similarly if we destroy the water
which is the lifeblood of the planet if
we destroy it in one place it'll come
back to to us elsewhere if only that
billions of people are going to want to
come to where there's water and they're
going to want to come to places like
around the Great Lakes and so on and the
Great Lakes are declining so it's in our
best interest to make sure that people
around the world are living within water
means and caring for their water because
the water refugees will be upon us and
what will we do then these are really
big questions and I'm disappointed that
they're not being debated in these
elections coming up